[موسيقى]
طب تم وطابته اوقاتكم اهلا بكم هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه هل هي استفتاء على
رئاسه جوبا ايدن ام ماذا اذا هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه وهذه التغطيه صباحا
جديد في امريكا ذهب المصوتين الى صناديق
الاقتراع من اجل تجديد دماء الكونجرس
الحسبان الرئيسيان الجمهوري والديمقراطي
يسعى يعني الى الاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ
وكذلك النواب نبدا من مجلس الشيوخ هذا
المجلس هذه المكون من 200 عضو الحل كما
ترون 50
ومثلها 50 مقعدا للجمهوريين الان المجلس
يجدد مجلس طوخ همم يجدد نفسه و خمسه
وثلاثين مقعد في 34 ولايه كما نشاهد
امامنا كل الولايه تشهد انتخابات على مقعد
واحد ما عدا ولايه اوكلاهوما التي تشهد
انتخابات على مقعديها في مجلس الشيوخ رغم
اننا نرى خمسه وثلاثين مقعدا مطروحا في
هذه الانتخابات لكن بعض المقاعد اهم من
بعض المقاعد الاخرى عدد كبير من هذه
المقاعد محسوم لاحد الحزبين مسبقا الاحمر
كما نشاهد بيد الجمهوريين والازرق كذلك
بيد الديمقراطيه يبقى التنافس في مساحات
ضيقه من اجل تحقيق الاغلبيه الاغلبيه تاتي
فقط باحتفاضي خلال الحزبين لجميع مقاعدهما
الحالي وانتاعه من الحزب الاخر الولايات
التي تضم المقاعد التنافسيه يطلق عليها
ولايات ساحات المعارك ها هي امامكم كما
ترونها باللون الازرق هي ما يسيطر عليها
الديمقراطيون حاليا ويريدون الاحتفاظ بها
اريزونا نيباده جورجيا نيو هامشر هذه
الولايات التي
مساحات حرب الولايات باللون الاحمر والتي
نشاهدها الان هذه الولايات يسيطر عليها
الجمهوريون ايضا يحاولون الحفاظ عليها
نتحدث عن ولايات مثل فلوريدا نور
كايرولينا وكذلك من سلفانيا
بالنسبه
اقل من طبعا همم الاولاد نضيق هذه
الاحتمالات
اكثر في ولايات ساحات المعارك التي نتحدث
عنها هنا تحديدا ننظر الى هذه المعارك
المحتدمه بن سلفانيا مثلا مقعدها مطروح
بعد التقاعد السيناتور الجمهوري باتومي
يتنافس على هذا المقعد الديمقراطي جون
فترمان وكذلك الجمهوري محمد اوز الاول
يدعمه وبالتاكيد الاخير يدعمه ترامب ايضا
هناك ولايه اخرى وصراع جديد في جورجيا
الصراع بين السنه ترا الديمقراطيه الحالي
رافاييل يورنو وكذلك الجمهوريه المدعوم من
ترامب
هذه الانتخابات في هذه الولايه تحمل
خصوصيه شديده سناتي طبعا على ذكريها لاحقا
في سياق هذه التغطيه اما المعركه
الاكبر فتكون في صحراء نيفادا بنا
السيناتور الديمقراطيه الحاليه كافيين
كورتيز ماستو وكذلك الجمهوريه الذي يدعمه
بالتاكيد ترامب ادم
استطلاعات الراي لم تقدم اي شيء مفيد بشان
هويه ال ال الفائز بينهما قد يكون هذا هو
المقعد الحاسب لهذه الانتخابات اذا لبنى
شد مفاجات في ولايه اخرى
[موسيقى]
انتهينا من الجزء الاول الان الى الجزء
الثاني في هذه الانتخابات المهمه ماذا
مجلس النواب الامريكي الغرفه الادنى من
الكونغرس هذه السيده التي نراها الان هي
نانسي تسعى للحفاظ على اغلبيه حزبها حزبها
الديمقراطيه في مجلس النواب اما كذا
المكان فيه زعيم الاقلي الجمهوريه يريد ان
يصبح رئيس المجلس الجديد بعد ان غابت
الاغلبيه عن حزبه لاربع سنوات الوضع
الحالي هو التالي
هذا المجلس يتكون من
مقعدا تحديدا لكن تشكيلته الحاليه ينقصها
ثلاثه انواع الاستقاله ما بين واحد منهم
ديمقراطي وهو شارلي الذي يرشح نفسه لمنصب
حاكم ولايه فلوريدا ايضا
توفيت دائما
وثانيه وهي الجمهوريه الثالثه عفوا هي
الجمهوريه جاكي ولروسكي وتذكرون جاكي هي
النائبه التي بحث عنها جول بعيدا بعد
وفاتها بشهرين
نعود اذن الى مجلس النواب بعد خصم المقاعد
الثلاثه التي تحدثنا عنها يتكون هذا
المجلس الحالي من اغلبيه ديمقراطيه ب 200
مقعدا وقال لي جمهوريه
ب212 متقعدا هذه الانتخابات الحاليه تشهد
تنافسنا على كل مقاعد المجلس يحتاج
الجمهوريون فقط الى سته مقاعد من اجل
الوصول الى الاغلبيه وبالتاكيد هي غايته
طبعا مع الحفاظ على ما بايديهم حتى الان
اما كل ما على الديمقراطيين ان يفعل
التالي
هو ان يحافظوا على ما يملكون الان وهي
مهمه ليست بالسهله من بين
دائره انتخابيه حصل المعركه في اقل من 40
منها هذه الدوائر التي يملك الجمهوريون
فيها الفرصه ويملكون الفرصه الانتزاع بها
من الديمقراطيين يقول بعض الخبراء ان
ساحات المعارك التي نتحدث عنها هي 37
دائره البعض الاخر يرى انها 34 دائره
نيويورك مثلا بها اربع دوائر حاسمه ولايه
كاليفورنيا فيها كذلك ثلاثه ولايات او
ثلاثه دوائر بن سلمان بها ايضا ثلاثه بها
ثلاثه دوائر نيفادا ايضا ثلاثه باقي
الولايات بها بين مقعد او مقعدين او لا
مقاعد حاسمه على الاطلاق ايه ده هذه
الانتخابات هي استفتاء على ذلك الرجل من
هو ذلك الرجل جو بايدن رغم انه قال انها
ليست استفتاء عليه بل استفتاء على
الديمقراطيه في الولايات المتحده لكن في
النهايه طبقا نتيجه الانتخابات كاشفه لراي
الامريكيين في ادارته حتى الان المزيد
دائما مع طاهر مباركه
[موسيقى]
انا جو بايدن الرئيس السادس والاربعون
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه عمري 80 عاما
قضيت منها 50 عاما في السياسه ولم ازل
في عهد اصبحت فاتوره جره الغاز في مطابخ
المواطنين ولتر البنزين في سياراتهم
واضاءه غرف نومهم تقدم تماما كما يفعله
الذين يقوتا يوميا ليبقي عيني على الحقيبه
النوويه واصبعيه على الزناد
في الخريف العمر الذي يصادف منتصف ولايه
الاولى اصل الى مكتب البيضاوي في الجناح
الغربي من البيت الابيض كل يوم لاجد كيف
راك ما طاقم ملفات البلاد الساخنه والعالم
الاكثر سخونه وبعدما استكملت مواجهه
كورونا وتداعيته الاقتصاديه خفضت تضخم
الذي لا يزال مرتفعا واعدت البطاله الى
مستويات ما قبلنا واقريت مع الكونجرس
قوانين ب 100 مليارات دولارات لكل منها
كقانون رقائق الالكترونيه والعلوم قانون
المناخ والصحه خطه تحفيز الاقتصاد وخطه
اعاده بناء البنيه التحتيه غير انك كثيرا
من هذه القوانين لما تاتي بعد ثمارا سريعه
اقطفها في انتخابات التجديد النصفيه التي
تعكر صفها قضايا الاجهاض والمخدرات
والسلاح المتللد والنظام الصحي وتلك
الجندريه منها هكذا لك
صحيح انني كبرت وقد اتعثر على سلم طائره
وهو ما يتوسله دونالد ترامب سبيلا للهجوم
الانتخابيه علي ولكني اظل الشهوب سابقاده
السيارات بسرعه جنونيه ولو كان في شبابي
صحيح انني كبرت وحصل ان اخطات مرارا في
خطابات ونسيت اسماء وخالفت مراسم واختلطت
علي امور وهو مابات الجمهوريون يعيرونني
به ايضا وانا ابن المؤسسه التشريعيه
العريقه والشهير بالخطابه والفصاحه وسن
القوانين رغم مشكله التلعثم عندي صغار
يشار اليه عاده كفاني رئيس كاثوليكي بعد
جون كينيدي الذي اغتيل وكنائب رئيس لاول
رئيس اسود وكول رئيس تنوب عنهم امراه رغم
ما تسمعونه من اتهامات بمخالطات لصيقه
للنساء
وبين ملف محلي افرغ منه واخر دولي يبقى
عالقا تطفو على سطح ذاكرتي صور عائله
صغيره
زوجه الاولى ليليا وسوره ابنتي وهما
اللتان توفيت في حادث سير بعيدا انتخابي
في مجلس الشيوخ وصوره بوم وهو ابن الذي
خسر معركته مع السرطان عندما كنت نائما
للراس وسوره هانتر نجل الاخر المتورط
بسمعه سيئه والاتهامات فساد في اوكرانيا
انا جو بايدن
نعم سيكتب التاريخ عن عهدي انني تسببت
بفوضه في افغانستان عندما سحبته جنوني
ايفاء لهم بوعودي ولكنه سيكتب ايضا انني
قتلت ايمن الظواهري دون ان ارسل له جنديا
واحدا على الارض واوروبا العجوز مثلي
والتي انحدر شخصيا منها منقسمه وضعيفه رغم
انني وقعت على توسيع ليشمل فنلندا والسويد
من اجل حمايتها بين انني احكم في وقت يبزغ
فجر اقطاب عالميه رائده جديده عينها على
ما تعتبره انها القوميه قد تبدا بروسيا في
اوكرانيا ولا تنتهي بالصيني
او الطامحه كائران والتي فشلت في اعادتها
الى الاتفاق النووي يقول للتاريخ ان هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه عاده ما تكون استفتاء
على الرئيس وماضيه ويقول للحاضر انها قد
تكون فتاه على الرئيس السابق ومستقبله
السياسي اما مستقبل السياسي انا فربما لم
يعد جمبني بالكثير انا
كل ذلك الشرح
المستفيض ان نذهب الى الارض وانا تم نتلمس
الواقع على الارض من مدينه هيرشي في
بنسلفانيا معنا كير غانم وكذلك سيكون ايضا
من مدينه
معنى من هناك تحديدا من جورجيا همم حسين
الطود وكذلك من نيويورك معنا طلال الحاج
اهلا بكم جميعا صباحكم سعيد بتوقيتكم
يومكم طويل نعلم ذلك يبدو ان البرد ايضا
همم
يعني يكون شويه قاسي طول اليوم لكن سخونه
هذه الانتخابات ليبدا اولا معك يارب اليوم
قد يكون الحاكم محسوم الديمقراطيين ولكن
التنافس على مجلس الشيوخ هل سيكون في
بنسلفانيا انتخاب ومزاج اخر جمهوري في
مجلس الشيوخ والحاكم يكون ديمقراطي ما
الذي يحدث
هذه المعركه بين المرشحين لمجلس الشيوخ
الى حد كبير جدا هي
معركه شخصيه بينها فترمانوس السبب هو ان
استطلاعات الراي بين الطرفين متقاربه جدا
هناك الكثير من الشعبيه لدى فتره من اصلا
لكنه اصيب بجلطه دماغيه وبعد ذلك فقد
الكثير في هذه الاستطلاعات في سلفانيا لا
يحبون اوس ولا يؤيدون بالضروره الجمهوريين
ولكنه فقدوا الثقه
طيب هل معنى ذلك
مزاجيه الناخب قد تذهب الى اي منهما
باعتبار انه هناك ربما مطالب هناك همم قد
يطرحها هذا المرشح
ولاء للحزب
ولاء الحزب موجود هناك ثلث الناخبين من
الجمهوريين هناك
الديمقراطيين الكلام الفصل هو للمستقلين
بالنسبه للمستقلين يرى الكثيرون في منطقه
بنسلفانيا ان الجمهوريين هم بوضع افضل
لمعالجه مشاكل
النساء
اكبر ليه الديمقراطيين للمحافظه على حقه
النائب من الممكن ان ترى في عائله واحده
رجل يصوت للجمهوريين وزوجته تصوت
لديموقراطيين والاصوات سوف تكون متقاربه
جدا بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك ثمانيه ملايين
ناخب وهناك اصلا
حتى الان باصواتهم سلام بس صوتك كير رشفه
ما فقدت تساعد ساذهب الى حسين طول وربما
اليك حسين مزاجيه الناخب في جورجيا همم
كيف همم تكون في هذه الولايه وما هي
القضايا التي تجذبها
صباح الخير عادل بعد اسابيع من الحملات
الانتخابيه ومن الخطابات وكلمات المرشحين
اليوم الناخبون هنا في جورجيا سيقولون
كلمتهم من خلال الاقتراع طبعا استطلاعات
الراي تظهر تقارب بين
المتنافسين المنافسين المرشحين الاساسيين
على الحزب الجمهوري والديمقراطيل
الديمقراطيه الحالي ومنافسه الجمهوريه
هيرش رغم ان ابي حسب موقع فانا همم واقر
الان يتقدم باستطاعات الراي على وراء ولكن
بنسبه ضائله طبعا المنافسه ترتدي هنا جورج
هي احدى الولايات التي توصى بانها ساحه
حسن انتخابيه في هذه الانتخابات الفائز
بمقعد مجلس الشيوخ هنا سيحدد همم او قد
يحدد الحزب الذي سيسيطر على مجلس الشيوخ
خلال العامين المقبلين طبعا همم الناخبون
هنا في همم تصويت المبكر وهمم سجلوا رقما
قياسيا
اكثر من مليون و500,000 ناخذ ادله
باصواتهم في الانتخابات او في التصويت
المبكر لهذا السبب يتوقع في ضوء هذه
الارقام ان يكون هناك اقبال كثيف جدا لا
سيما بعد التحشيد وبعد التحفيز من قبل
المرشحين ومن قبل داعمهم من حزبين
ديمقراطي والجمهوري ويحث
جورجيا على الاقبال بكثافه للتصويت من اجل
الفوز في هذه الانتخابات نتوقع ان يكون
هناك همم اقبال كبير يجب ان نشير ايضا الى
معركه وايضا على مستوى منصب الحاكم بين
السيسي ابرامز المرشح الديمقراطيه وبين
الحاكم ابراهيم كامل طيب اذهب الى نيويورك
حسين ساذهب الى هناك بالتحديد الى طلال
الحاج من نيويورك طلال همم يعني اعذرني
ربما انت في وضع الاجواء بارده جدا ولكن
نيويورك هل هي ببروده همم حسم مجلس الشيوخ
زعيم الديمقراطيين في المجلس ام انها قد
تكون هناك مفاجاه اييي حمراء على منصب
الحاكم
فعلا عادل الاجواء بارده ببعض الشيء ولكن
المعركه ساخنه هناك منافسه قويه على منصب
حاكم الولايه وهناك منافسه قويه ايضا على
منصب السيناتور الممثل لولايه نيويورك في
مجلس الشيوخ تعرف ان شك شو ما هو رئيس
الديمقراطين داخل مجلس الشيوخ اي مركز
قيادي يعادل مثلا في مجلس النواب ولكنه
يواجه معركه همم
حاميه جدا على منصبه وتجديده اذا خسر
الشومر واذا خسرت الحاكم الديمقراطيه
للولايه وهي
كاتر ستكون زلزال في الحزب الديمقراطيه
فعلا لان هذه الولايه المكونه من 20 مليون
نسمه ثلاثه عشره مليون ناخد 70% منهم
مسجلون رسميا ديمقراطيين
اه سيكون هذه فعلا زلزال يبش يبشره لا
يبشر بالخير بالنسبه لبقيه انتخابات
الديمقراطيه في انها بقيه انحاء الولايه
هذه هل هناك من مؤشرات طلال على ذلك يعني
حتى الان على الاقل قراءه مسبقه نعم نعم
نعم مثلا مثلا همم الحاكم التي استلمت هذا
المنصب في اغسطس الماضي بعد ان واجه حاكم
ولايه اندرو كوم وفضيحه همم مع موظفاته في
داخل همم الحكومه المحليه همم هي تواجه
معركه صعبه جدا مع ليزر الجمهوري وهنا
نائب من جمهوري ولكن كانت في قبل اشهر
ثلاثه اشهر تقريبا تتفوق عليه
ب 10% من الاصوات قبل ذلك كان
% الان هو متفوق عليها بفاصله سته في 10
همم في استطلاعات الراي المستقله طبعا 4%
من الناخبين لم يحددوا بعد من المستقلين
كيفيه تصويبهم هذه كما قلت ولايه
ديموقراطيه بامتياز ولا ينافسها في ذلك
الا ولادته كاليفورنيا على سبيل المثال
ولكن همم هناك مخاوف كبيره دفعت بالرئيس
باجر الى القدوم هنا الى نيويورك منطقه
اسمها يوم كارز همم ليله الاحد والوقوف
الى جانب همم كثر الهوكن اللي جنب الاصوات
لها والحشد تايدي لها هناك معركه هنا في
همم
نيويورك
يواجهونه فيها صعوبه كبيره اذا خسروا هذه
المعركهتين فهذا لا يبشر بالخير بتاتا همم
الديمقراطيين ستكون ليله صعبه وتكون ستكون
ايام قادمه صعبه كما تعرف ان النتائج لن
تخرج اليوم بسرعه لانه هناك
50-25% يصوتون بريديا هناك همم مليون ونصف
في هذه الولايه صوتوا همم مبكرا كل ذلك
يبدا عده بعد الساعه 9:00 مساء بتوقيت نيو
نعم سنكون معك بالتاكيد طلال اعود الى
حسين سريعا حسين منصب الحاكم ربما هناك
ايضا حديث حول هذا المنصب حيث ان في
جورجيا همم نظره سريعه قبل ان اذهب الى
قير اذا تكرمت
حتى الان حتى الان عادل
استطلاعات الراي تشير الى تفوق الحاكم
الحاليه الجمهوري برانكام على المنافسته
الديمقراطيه السيسي ابرز ولكن السيسي
ابرامز غردت البارحه قالت انها لن تستسلم
وستفعل كل ما في وسعها من اجل ان تخدم
الجورجيين كما قالت وشاهدنا ايضا تدخل من
هي هيلاري كلينتون برساله خاصه عبر تويتر
تحث همم الناخبين هنا في جورجيا للتصويت
لصالح السيسي عبر رمز
وتخوفهم اذا صحاب تعبير من ان اا بقاء
الحاكم الجمهوري يعني همم بقاء او محاربه
او همم بالنسبه لحقوق حق الاجهاض همم
سيكون كارثيه على النساء هنا في جورجيا
لهذا دعتهم الى الدفاع عن هذا الحق
بالتصويت للسيسي عبر رمز ولكن استطلاعات
الراي حتى الان تفضل او هي في صالح همم
ابراهيم كامل لاسيما ان ابراهيم كانت لديه
علاقه جيده كما يقال هنا مع الناخبين
المستقلين
قد يلعبون دورا كبيرا في هذه الانتخابات
وهو يعني حافظ على علاقه معهم من حيث
القوانين التي اصدرها المتعلقه بالاصلاح
الضريبه او بزياده الرواتب بنسبه لموظفي
الولايه والمدرسين فيها كير اذا عدت اليك
في بنسلفانيا مؤشرات على اين يتجه الناخب
عند صناديق الاقتراع لشخوص ربما شخصيات
محبوبه لديه هل سيؤثر ايضا على فترمان همم
الجلطه التي تعرضت او تعرض لها هل ستؤثر
على حظوظها ام سيكسب التعاطف
اثرت كثيرا على التعاطف واثره كثيرا على
الثقه به كان رجل يتمتع بتقدم كبير جدا
على منافسه الجمهوريه امام ولكنه خسر هذا
التقدم بشكل كبير جدا حاول خلال الفتره
الماضيه ان يؤكد للناخبين على انه يتمتع
بصحه جيده جاء ايضا الرئيس
اوباما في مهرجان انتخابي كبير في خلال
هذه الفئه لدعم هذا المرشح بالذات وكان
الهدف منهم هو ان يدفعوا همم
القلقين من القريبين من الحزب الديمقراطي
او الديمقراطيين وبشكل خاص على افارقه
الامريكيين يدفعوهم للذهاب الى صناديق
الاقتراع لانهم لا يريدون اخي صارت هذا
المركز وبدون شك- يفهمون الضعف الذي اصيب
به فتنه
من مدينه هيرشي في بنسل الدنيا شكرا جزيلا
لك شكرا موصول ايضا من جورجيا حسين الطود
وكذلك من حيث البرد الاكثر هناك ربما طلال
الحاج شكرا جزيلا لك سنكون معكم في هذه
التغطيه
[موسيقى]
هذه التقنيه ما زالت في بدايتها وكذلك
الانتخابات الامريكيه فاصل ونعود اليكم لا
تذهبوا بعيدا
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله
الرئيس الامريكي له على تويتر
الى التصويت في الانتخابات النصفيه وغرد
وايضا قائلا انه يوم الانتخابات اجعله
اصواتكم مسموعه
وفيما يتجه ملايين الامريكيين الى مراكز
التصويت للاقتراع في الانتخابات النصفيه
اعلنتها السلطات في مقاطعه ماري كوبا في
ولايه اريزونا التي تشهد منى
تعزيز الاجراءات الامنيه قبل فتح صناديق
على الاقتراح حضر المسؤولون في المقاطعه
من ان السلطات المحليه لديها سياسه 09:00
اتجاه كل من يحاول ترهيب الناخبين تشهد
هذه الولايه كوبا اا عفوا هذه المنطقه
التي يفوق عدد سكانها 4 ملايين نسمه تشهد
توتر متزايده منذ انتخابات عام 2020 بسبب
اعلان الحزب الجمهوري في الولايه عدم ثقته
بنظام الاختراع فيها
اكشن
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب قال
في تجمع انتخابيه في مدينه ديتونا بولايه
اوهايو انه سيصدر اعلانا كبيرا في الخامس
عشر من نوفمبر في اشاره الاغترابه من
اعلان الترشح مجددا للانتخابات الرئاسيه
الوجه
[موسيقى]
لو فيفتي
[تصفيق]
ميشيل ابو نجم اهلا بك سيد ميشيل يعني
لاسالك اولا عن هذه او قبل ذلك ايضا ينضم
الينا من بيروت الدكتور سامي نادر استاذه
الاقتصاد والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا بكم طيب
ليبدا اولا مع الاستاذ ميشيل بدايه اعلان
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب انا
يوم الخامس عشر سيشهد مفاجاه كبيره واعلان
هام جدا كيف تقرا ذلك هل
هذه المعطيات بدايه او هذه الانتخابات
ستعطيه دفعه ام انه سيكون ارتدادا الى
الوراء
علينا ان نقول ان الاجابه على هذا السؤال
تفترض بنا ان نكون على الاطلاع على
النتيجه التي تستخرج من صناديق
اذا نجح الجمهوريون في الفوز
بالاغلبيه كانت مجلس النواب وهو شيء شبه
مؤكد او كان في مجلس الشيوخ وهو شيء مرجح
اذا نجح في هذين المجلسين فان ذلك سوف
يشكل منصه
للرئيس السابق دون ترامب لتمكينه من
الترشح من موقع قوي للانتخابات الرئاسيه
في العام 2024
في هذا السياق علينا انه يشير الى ان
لترامب كان دور كبير في تعيين المرشحين
الذين ياخذون الانتخابات نذكر هنا بان
العديد من المرشحين قد خرجوا من انفسهم من
هذا السباق لانهم لم يحضوا
بدعم من قبل ترامب او لانه كانوا خلال همم
نهايه عهد ترامب من غير المحدثين
للسياساته او لكيفيه تعامله مع انتصار
بيدن في الانتخابات الرئاسيه الفائته هذه
ملاحظه ثانيه طيب انا بدي انا ايضا ان
اتسائل سيد ميشيل اليوم يعني هذه الخطوه
من الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب رغم انه
قال سابقا ان الانتخابات الرئاسيه قد سرقت
منهم هل سيكون ذلك دافعا
مؤيد الحزب الجمهوري بالذهاب الى صناديق
الاقتراع الاختياري من يمثلون
نعم علينا ان نقول ان الرئيس ترامب لم
يكتفي فقط بالاعلان ان هذه الانتخابات
انتخابات الرئاسيه السابقه قد سرقت منه
قبل عامين لبن انه خلال العامين المنقديين
من فك على التاكيد ان هذه الانتخابات
كصوره كانت منها ولم تتوقف الامور عند هذا
الحد لان اليوم هناك نسبه لا باس بها من
الجمهوريين لا بل من بين المرشحين
الجمهوريين الذين يؤكدون كما ترامب بان
انتخابات قصرك من الحزب الجمهوري وان
هؤلاء المرشحين
يرفضون سلفا خسارتهم لانهم سيعتبرون عندها
انه كان هناك تلاعب بهذه الانتخابات
وبكيفيه عد الاصوات وغير ذلك الانتخابات
عن طريق البريد الانتخابات عن طريق
الوسائل الالكترونيه وغير ذلك
الاهم من ذلك كله ان ان اسمح لي بس 20
ثانيه
خلال هذين العامين لم يجب عن المسرح
السياسي لا بل انه اثبت انه ما حاضرا واذا
نجح الجمهوريون فانه حضور سيكون اقوى لبن
ان الاداره الامريكيه ستجد نفسها محاصره
بترامب وبطبع بالجمهوريه اتفضل سنتحدث عن
ذلك ايضا في سياق هذه التغطيه لكن دعني
اذهب الى بيروت الدكتور سامي نادي الاستاذ
الاقتصاد والعلاقات الدوليه هذه
الانتخابات هل هي انتخابات
لامريكا كما اشار جو بايدن ام ان ناخذ
الامريكي
سيجري استفتاء على سياسات بايجن
الاقتصاديه اولا باعتقادك
الى حد الى حد بعيد هو استفتاء على
السياسه التي
ينتهشها الرئيس اكان على المستوى
الاقتصادي الداخلي او كان ايضا على
المستوى الخارجي من دون شك ان الاولويه
بالنسبه
الامريكي اليوم هي اولويه اقتصاديه
بيظل موجه التضخم التي تجتاح العالم والتي
تجتاح امريكا ايضا صحيح ان امريكا مصابه
اقل من الدول اخرى مثل الدول اوروبا ولكن
هنالك انهيار القدره الشرائيه للمواطن
الامريكي لم يشهدها منذ عقود منذ
السبعينات وهي اليوم ازمه تبدو انها
مستدامه وذلك بالرغم من كل ما قام به او
حاول ان يقوم به همم اداره بيضا من
استثمار بقطاعات البنا التحتيه اليوم
الوضع الاقتصادي لا يلعب ابدا لصالح
الرئيس بيدا وهنالك ايضا بعد خارجي
واستفتاء على السياسه الخارجيه قد يكون
يعني ابلغ تعبير عنها تلك الرساله الذي
وجهها 30 نائب ديمقراطي يطلبون منها من
الرئيس ان يحس
الاوكرانيين الى الذهاب الى طاوله
المفاوضات صحيح انهم لم ينتقدوا الدعم
العسكري
لاوكرانيا ولكن هنالك اليوم كمال المول من
ان هذه الحرب تطول هذه الحرب تكلف امريكا
على المستوى الاقتصادي
وكما من يقول نحن اولى بهذه الاموال الذي
يجب ان تنفق في الداخل الامريكي صحيح انها
مساله ما زالت يعني
سيجالا في الداخل الامريكي ولكن
كان الطرف الجمهوري الذي يريد ان يتشدد في
مساله المساعدات العسكريه المرسله دكتور
يعني اسمح لي هنا هنا تحديدا اذا تكرمت
يعني ايضا رحل تلك
المسؤوليه ما بين روسيا واحيانا حتى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه باعتبار انه
زياده النفط هو همم رحله الى الى الدول
المنتجه للنفس هل هذا كافي ليقناع الناخب
الامريكي
بان يعود ليصوت الديمقراطين
لا اعتقد ان الناخب الامريكي يقتنع بذلك
لان كما قلنا الهم الاول هو الهم
الاقتصادي هو يريد نتائج
لا يريد مبررات ولا يريد اسباب ولعل ابلغ
دليل على ذلك الانتخابات التي اتت بالرئيس
بالكليتون همم رئيسا والذي استطاع ان يهزم
من كان منتصر في الحرب الخليج الاولى
الرئيس جورج بوش الاب وبالتالي يعني هذا
دليل اضافي على ان الاولويه بالنسبه الى
الناخب الامريكي كانت وماتت هل هي
الاولويه الاقتصاديه هي الحفاظ على قدرته
الشرائيه هي فرص العمل همم هو يهتم بامور
اخرى ربما هنالك امر على المستوى
الاجتماعي قد يشكل حافزا للنساء هي مساله
الاجهاض ولكن همم همم هذا نعم يشكل اطعاطف
لدى الناخب من الجندر النساء ولكن تبقى
الاولويه اليوم من دون اي شك الاولويه
الاقتصاديه سيد ميشيل ابو نجم يعني اليوم
يفعله الرئيس الحالي
باعتبار انه المشاكل التي يصدرها الى
الخارج واللقاء اللون هل من الممكن ان
يجري ان ناخذ الامريكي همم او يتخذ خطوات
عقابيه اللي هي الحزب الديمقراطي نتيجه
لهذه السياسات اليوم
نعم في الواقع الرئيس بيدن يعني هذه
المساله ومن هنا قال اكثر من مره خلال
الايام الاخيره الماضيه ان هذه الانتخابات
ليست استفتاء على سياسته وانما استفتاء
على الديمقراطيه وهو بشكل ما يريد حرف
الانتباه انتباه الناخب عن المشاكل
اليوميه كانت ارتفاع الاسعار او الغلاء او
او التضخم وغير ذلك هذه ملاحظه والاملاحظه
الثانيه علينا ان نشير وهنا شاطر الراي
زميلنا من بيروت ان الناخب ال- الامريكي
لا ينظر الى الانتخابات من زاويه السياسات
الخارجيه على بال ما يهمه بالدرجه الاولى
هو ما يجري داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه طيب من هنا نحن نرى ان هناك
انقسامات ان هناك انقسامات مثلا في موضوع
الحرف في اوكرانيا هناك انكسامات ليس فقط
داخل الحسبه الديمقراطي والرساله الثلاثين
عضوا في هذا الحزب وهما اليسار داخل الحزب
يعني همم يعني
لرؤيه بعيدا لهذه الانتخابات دعنا نستمع
الى ما قاله ونعود
نموذج
طيب ااا يعني ارجو ان تكونوا قد استمعتم
الى ما قاله الرئيس الامريكي اذا ما فاز
الجمهوريون سيد ميشيل حياته ستكون صعبه في
واشنطن توافق
بالطرسه تكون صعبه خصوصا كما قلنا بدايه
اذا نجح الجمهوريون في الفوز بالمجلسين
الشيوخ والنواب بالطبع هذا يعني ان الرئيس
الامريكي ستخرج منه كافه الصالحيات
كل ما هو تشريع كل ما هو ميزانيه كل ما هو
التصديق على معاهدات او اتفاقيات او غير
ذلك كل ذلك سيتطلب موافقه
الرئيس الامريكي في حاجه للتفاوض
والتواصل الصفقات مع مع الجمهوريين حتى
يستطيع الاستمرار ما زال امامه عامين
دكتور سامي اقل من 30 ثانيه همم القادمه
كيف تراهما الان
انا اعتقد ان مرشح فوز حزب الجمهوري ربما
ليس بموجه حمراء كما يشار ولكن يبدو انهم
سيفوزون بمجلس الشيوخ وبمجلس النواب لذلك
سوف تكون وفق التعبير الامريكي الاداره
بحكم البطه العرجاء اي لن تتمكن من تنفيذ
اجنتها السياسيه شكرا جزيلا الدكتور سامي
نادر استاذ الاقتصاد والعلاقات الدوليه
والشكر موصول ايضا للكاتب الصحفي ميشيل
ابو نجم
شكرا بنا جزيلا لكم لكن قبل الشكر الرئيس
الامريكي دونالد ترامب وبعد خسارته عام
2020 قال لطالما رفع شعار ان الانتخابات
سرقت منه وانها مزوره والان في الانتخابات
النصفيه بارزه ظهوره كادعم للمرشحين
للجمهوريين بشكل كبير ما تاثير ذلك دعونا
نعم
[موسيقى]
ته
عام 2020
قد يفوز فيها بالاغلبيه بالكونجرس او
يخسرها
في الانتخابات
ترامب لاعب دورا هاما وقوته كانت بارزه
للاعيان بشكل واضح القوه التي لا يزال
يمارسها لا تزال عميقه ودائما
لكن ما قد يقوضوا من حدود الجمهوريين
بتاثير ترامب هو ما يواجهه الرئيس السابق
من دعاوي قضائيه تتمحور حولتها من بالتهرب
الضريبي والتدخل لقلب نتائج الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في 2020 واحتمال وجود دور له في
الهجوم العنيف الذي شنه انصاره على
الكونجرس اضافه الى حياذته وثائق السريه
من الارشيف الرئاسيه
الرئيس السابق ترامب استمر في التاثير
بشكل كبير في الحملات الانتخابيه وكان
اكثر صراحه في الاعراب عن دعمه للمرشحين
بحسب اراء خبراء فانه لا يمكن حسبه فائده
مساهمه ترامب في الانتخابات النصفيه على
الحزب الجمهوري الا انهم وصفوا مشاركه
ترامب في الحملات الانتخابيه بالمقامره
كونها لا تؤثر على الناخب الجمهوري فقط
ومسيره ترامب في انتخابات الرئاسه عام
2024 انما على الناخب الديمقراطي ايضا
بدفعه للمش هاتف الانتخابات النصفيه
فحسب تحليل نشره معهد بروكرنس فان
الانتخابات النصفيه تمثل اختبار وجوديا
لترامب وسلطه
وستعددون نتائجها قوته المستقبليه في
الحزب الجمهوري واحتمال ظهور اصوات معارضه
لترامب بشكل علني داخل الحزب تؤثر على
فرصه للمشاركه في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
بعد ان وضحنا جزء من الصوره هذه التغطيه
مستمره لتوضيح الاجزاء الاخرى الان استطيع
ان اشكركم اذا بعد قليل ميسون
[موسيقى]